L'importanza del quantum computing è al tempo stesso sottovalutata
e enormemente sopravvalutata allo stesso tempo.
Anche se non sostituirà i computer convenzionali
l'innovazione quantistica rappresenta un nuovo paradigma di computing.
I computer quantistici possono lavorare in sinergia con il computing attuale
infrastruttura per risolvere problemi complessi che in precedenza erano
considerati impraticabili o impossibili.
Questo può cambiare radicalmente le cose.
Per esempio la difficoltà di fattorizzare numeri grandi
nei loro numeri primi è la base della crittografia
moderna. Per la dimensione dei numeri usati nella crittografia moderna a chiave pubblica
privata questo calcolo richiederebbe
al computer convenzionale più veloce oltre 300 trilioni di anni.
Per un computer quantistico su larga scala che lavora
con l'algoritmo di Shor questo calcolo potrebbe richiedere secondi.
Problemi complessi come questo esistono in tutti i settori.
Le potenziali applicazioni del quantum computing
sono vastissime.
I computer quantistici stanno già diventando più grandi
e più capaci,
mentre puntiamo ad affrontare problemi sempre più complessi.
Dal 2016, IBM ha reso i computer quantistici accessibili
al pubblico tramite un sito web con un'interfaccia grafica che
assomiglia a uno spartito musicale.
e il kit di sviluppo software Qiskit
che permette agli utenti di programmare i computer quantistici.
Scienziati dentro e fuori dal mondo aziendale
stanno eseguendo esperimenti
tramite portali simili. Stanno esplorando approcci alla chimica
e ai problemi di machine learning cercando di capire
che tipo di domande possono porsi
e come le formuleranno
una volta che la tecnologia sarà più avanzata. Adesso è il
momento giusto per i leader aziendali di prepararsi
per il quantum. Le condizioni sono favorevoli per sperimentare
ed espandere questa tecnologia fondamentalmente nuova.
Le organizzazioni che cercano di essere all'
avanguardia di questo cambiamento trasformazionale
coglieranno un vantaggio competitivo. Questa formazione
ti preparerà ad iniziare il tuo percorso quantistico!